Now to implement a bag we need
the concept of a pennant.
So what's that?
Here's the formal definition.
A pennant is a tree with two to
the k nodes and a unary root and
that root has a child.
And the child is the root of
a complete binary subtree.
Okay, that was a lot of words,
here's a picture.
This pennant has a root and one child.
And notice that the child is the parent
of a complete binary subtree.
Now a pennant has to have
a power of two number of nodes.
Now remember that a complete
binary tree has to have
almost a power of two number of nodes,
in particular, 2 to the k minus 1.
And therefore, when we add the root,
we get a power of 2.
Okay, now let's see how we can quickly
do interesting operations on pennants.
Let's call the root little x and
let's call its complete binary
sub-tree child, capital X sub s.
Now suppose I give you a second pennant.
This pennant has a root node, little y,
and a child sub-tree, capital Y sub s.
And let's further suppose that these
pennants have exactly the same size
even though I haven't
really drawn them to scale.
So how do you quickly combine these
two pennants into a new pennant?
Here's one way,
let's choose one of the roots to be
the new root of a combined pennant.
Let's pick x for example.
So let's chop X off and let's make
it the root of the new pennant.
Let's take the other root and
let's make it the new only child of X.
So that X is unary.
Now since we have two
complete subtrees left and
the subtrees are both exactly the same
size, I can make them both children of y
and together they'll still be
a compete binary sub tree.
Now notice that this new
blob is still a pennant.
It's got a unary root and
it's got a complete binary sub tree.
Now both of the original
pennants were size 2 to the k.
So that means the combined pennant will
have 2 to the k plus 2 to the k or
2 to the k plus 1 nodes.
So combining two equal sized
pennants into a new pennant is
pretty quick and easy.
Similarly, you can split a pennant
into two smaller pennants and
it will be just as easy, essentially by
running the same steps in reverse and
rearranging pointers accordingly.